si una bomba acaba de caer sobre este
edificio residencial en mariupol desde
hace días las fuerzas rusas han
bombardeado el estratégico puerto
ucraniano los civiles atrapados están en
un estado de shock y desesperación
no tenemos electricidad ni nada para
comer no hay medicinas no nos queda nada
[Música]
los cadáveres yacen en las calles se
están cavando fosas comunes los agujeros
de los bombardeos han convertido las
casas en escombros cercada por las
fuerzas rusas la ciudad de más de
400.000 habitantes sufre una crisis
humanitaria los intentos de evacuar a
los civiles han fracasado el gobierno ha
acusado a las fuerzas rusas de
bombardear los corredores humanitarios
así que los jóvenes y los ancianos
esperan en el lugar más seguro que hay
bajo tierra estoy muy triste por nuestra
gente en nuestra ciudad por los niños
sigue electricidad ni agua y con
suministros cada vez más escasos algunos
residentes hambrientos y desesperados
han recurrido a los saqueos los soldados
ucranianos han intentado preservar un
mínimo de orden
por favor dejen de robar todos
necesitamos vivir juntos esta es nuestra
ciudad porque están rompiendo ventanas
porque están robando en las tiendas
situada en el sureste de ucrania en el
mar de azov se cree que mariupol está en
el punto de mira de rusia como posible
lugar para reclamar una victoria
simbólica y temprana en su intento de
conectar el donbass separatista en el
este con crimea en el sur pero la
resistencia a las fuerzas invasoras ha
sido feroz